la famille Milo Bourassa n'est pas la
seule à vouloir voter par anticipation
aujourd'hui
c'était vraiment surprenant de voir ils
sont nombreux à attendre enfile devant
les bureaux de vote
leur fils Noah en a même profité pour
faire son devoir de citoyen
de l'autre côté du spectre Marie-Flore
Bellemare 99 ans de Saint-Étienne des
grès tiens elle aussi à voter
ça serait Popi
vous auriez dans la région de Québec les
électeurs ont parfois attendus jusqu'à
une heure avant de voter pilote quand
même tout le tour au complet on a pour
1h30 à l'intérieur bon ça se voit sur
des chaises pour nous encourager
avancer tranquillement le vote par
anticipation se déroule dimanche et
lundi depuis la pandémie se vote à Bondy
aux élections municipales et fédérales
on voit que le vote par anticipation est
de plus en plus populaire en élections
en élection à savoir si le contexte de
la covid va inciter les gens à se
présenter davantage au vote par
anticipation je ne serai pas dire on
peut le penser depuis une vingtaine
d'années le vote par an participation
aux élections provinciales a augmenté
malgré une légère baisse aux dernières
élections les électeurs apprécient la
flexibilité de la formule question
d'horaire en fait avec les enfants le
travail le lundi c'est un petit peu
moins facile ça va être fait
une corvée comme un devoir collection
Québec tente par tous les moyens de
rendre le plus accessible possible ici
Marie-Josée paquet como Radio-Canada
Montréal